[Music]
there's another super important lead-up
to the three beat we've which has to do
with understanding how the arms are
crossing so look at my arms right on top
and left on top and right on top and
left on top right crosses left crosses
right that's the feeling that's what it
feels in the end you can't count all the
beats and crosses they're all they're
overlapping and happening too quickly in
the end you just feel who left crosses
right crosses left across this right
crosses so we're gonna get a feeling for
that
so you just wrap have your plug up wrap
them up and face me and give me ten and
put your your this is your right hand
put it on top okay so your left your
left hand is on the bottom you're just
going to look to your left shoulder a
little bit and that pulls your left hand
on to its own track right so you can
just fall back along the wheel plane and
come over the top and get back to where
it was but now it's on top then you look
to the right side and again your pulse
your right hand over to the track on
your right side it falls back and goes
on top now if you didn't get a turn
you'd go like this and then you'd be on
this track they'd be on a wall plane and
we don't want a wall playing for this we
want it's going to be wheel crossing
from wheel playing the wheel plane and
your wall plans are in front behind you
like your notice is to a wall in the
back your head is to a wall your wheel
plans are like train tracks running past
by the foot that's having your shoulders
so we're we're your right hand on top
okay so turn this way left hand come
back go on the top look to the right
shoulder right you go on top left key go
on the top right comes on top let's just
go feeling for that now I'm just gonna
come back to your right on top and add
poi same thing super simple but it's
important to get a feeling for it
turn this way with me and now you're
left poi can just fall back cross over
and finished with a whole circle back on
the right side
turn towards your right shoulder and
then you're right poi can fall back and
cross over and it finishes doing extra
circle so all we start that turn because
that lets this fall back if I don't do
that it's gonna be on a wheat on a wall
plane turn this way go over finish
finish make sure you finish with circles
this way finished with the circle things
from circle you're gonna practice this
so you can go left right left right and
what's really important is to whatever's
on top just stays there
only the one on the bottom moves only
the right knees then only the left is
only the right moves only the left so
you say to yourself right circles over
left circles over right mixed across and
really see each time that you're really
making that cross with your forearms so
once you got a feeling for that you
should add something you're gonna add
making both for its split time circles
in between make some circles then you
can just stop it seems to be left boy it
crosses over then circles with both then
the right poi comes back goes over and
circles with both and I can go can this
can be really floppy I just want you
really have the feeling for circles with
the arms crossed super important that
all this like neural science stuff
happens you make circles but you can
stop in between it first left way
crosses and make circles and you can
stop and even if it's all you know a bit
floppy that still does something
important now for a few of you what's
gonna work is to get to a point where
you can have them both circling I'm
going forward split time my this would
be your right arm on the bottom and
while keeping them both circling I can
let you can let the right arm go out and
be on top but that does you don't have
to do that now just for a few of you
that'll work
but I've got a whole plan how to get the
rest of you into it
because
we keep speeding that up that become a
c3 beat we've so that's sort of like I
don't know a skip like a secret level
thing but you don't need to worry about
that if it seems far out but make sure
you do do the left goes over in circles
the right goes over in circles you a few
circles in between both and that lays
down some really important stuff and
when we come back soon and we're going
to review that you've got all of this
you know good enough and they're going
to learn three beat week
[Applause]
[Music]